hello everyone I'm Julie Banderas along
with Joey Jones Nicole Sapphire Dr
Nicole Sapphire and Raymond aroyo and
welcome to the big weekend show the big
story tonight out of office President
Biden is on island time as his
reelection hopes look dimmer by the day
Biden enjoying rest and relaxation in
warm St Croy and as usual ignoring
reporters any reaction to Maine dropping
Trump from the ballot May resolution
uh yeah I'm there with you I don't have
any New Year's resolutions either while
he's busy at the beach with his vacation
from reality Southern border crossing
surged to new records since December 1st
over
286,000 migrants have already crossed
now a caravan of nearly 6,000 more is
quickly making its way North into the US
Republicans calling out Biden for a
dereliction of Duty as he seems to
Simply ignore this spiral in crisis Fox
News correspondent Lucas tomson is
following Biden in St Croy happy New
Year
Lucas happy New Year Julie many critics
look at the southern Border in the
situation there is one of the reasons
the president's poll numbers have tanked
one Republican congresswoman from
Arizona says it has Democrats attention
now
too Republicans are really pushing for
border security I mean you even have
Democrat Governors like the Democrat
Governor in Arizona ktie Hobs saying the
Biden Administration is failing
miserably and so I I hope we can reach a
deal with Biden where he changes border
security policies um but then he has to
implement
them you mentioned that new migrant
Caravan heading north through Mexico
there's some 8,000 people in there the
group's leader recently spoke to the
cameras the president of the United
States must help us as we are migrants
in reality some of us only go to the US
for four or five six seven years and
then return to our
country for this reason we demand that
Joe Biden help
us as you mentioned Julie there's been
286,000 migrant encounters at the
southern Border in December that's the
highest ever in the in a month in
American history breaking the previous
record set 3 months ago there have been
770,000 encounters since October first
making the first quarter of this new
fiscal year also the highest in American
history that's more people than the
population of Seattle in just the past 3
months here's former DHS acting
secretary Chad wolf whatever it is that
this Administration puts in place it
encourages instead of deterring this
illegal Behavior again most Americans
like immigrants uh we like legal
immigration not illegal immigration
which is what we are seeing
today and the justice department now
threatens to sue Texas governor Greg
Abbott over a bill he signed into law
last week which gives his State the
right to arrest and Deport migrants
Abbott says he's going to fight this all
the way to the US Supreme Court there's
no doubt next year the Supreme Court is
going to be very busy Julie oh yes they
are indeed Lucas Tomlinson thank you
very much President Biden meantime isn't
breaking a sweat as he soaks up some
Island Sun that's because he has the
media still doing all his dirty work as
it sells broken biomics to the American
people but are you buying I don't know
about that they aren't doing a very good
job because Americans aren't getting
fooled the bomic Biden's formula for
strong economic growth from the bottom
up is not only driving a surge in the US
economy and a boom in large scale
infrastructure it's so much greater than
even the experts in economic stuff
expected it to be look at the numbers
and bomic is working from the
perspective of economic management
dealing with what's dealt you President
Biden is just not getting the praise he
deserves the best economic performance
of any president since Franklin Delano
rosev I'm gonna tell you the truth I
think I think Joe Biden has a better
story to tell than for reelection than
Obama did what I want what they're
having it's not even New Year's Eve yet
my God a new Fox News poll tells a
little different story and asound
astounding 66% of people said that 2023
was a year to forget for our country
only a quarter of Americans thought it
was a good year even residents in
Biden's hometown of Scranton
Pennsylvania have had
enough this economy
sucks I mean everything's going up
except you know paychecks it's tougher
for people you know so how could he be
seeing it through our eyes if you know
it's just gotten tougher I feel like for
everybody I don't think any of them see
it through Through The Eyes of the
people I think they all see it Through
The Eyes of
Washington it's got wors I'm a
registered Democrat but I'm not happy
okay there you go registered Democrats
not happy and that is someone who voted
into Biden into office I mean this is a
perfect example of buyer remorse well
elections has consequences and
unfortunately we are all living through
them right now now to be fair 2023
didn't see the recession that this time
last year everyone was warning about
which is okay so let's celebrate that I
guess but that doesn't mean that we
should go out there and start
celebrating this biomics it doesn't
matter how many times they continue to
say biomics it doesn't mean things are
peachy keen bottom line is you still
have the costs of things are still very
high yes they're not increasing at the
same rate but it's still the cost of
goods are still 3% higher than they were
last year people are not feeling the
benefits yes you're starting to see some
mortgage rates come down but the cost of
living the um your utilities your
mortgages everything is just so
unaffordable for the American people
right now and when people are going to
the store they don't have that
disposable income they're not able to
put in their savings and the reality is
under Trump they had a lot more
spendable income I'm sorry it was just
better under Trump I mean you were
laughing through that but I think that
was nervous laughter near tears I think
you were actually close to crying well
look the media spin on this is so absurd
I mean crazy Julie this is if your house
is flooding and somebody says it's okay
the hydration is going to be spectacular
for you people I mean that's basically
what they're telling us when you dig
into this fox poll it's really for the
Biden Administration this is a disaster
61% of Democrats 93% of Republicans and
85% of Independents say this is a bad
economy for them and all you have to do
is look at the underlying evidence here
61% of Americans living paycheck to
paycheck you got 20 million Americans
who are not paying their utility bills
something is clearly wrong with this
economy and the rank crazy spending of
Joe Biden has really not helped matters
much the debt is going through the roof
we're at what $33 trillion of debt
that's $100,000 for every man woman and
child in America I don't think people
don't forget the migrants too not just
migrants not just Americans but all the
migrants all the migrants that we also
are responsible for now and that these
cities are having to absorb and that's
why these cities are now BN and Joey the
top two issues are immigration and
inflation and those are two
things that the Biden and AD
Administration has failed horribly on um
he is in denial about inflation and he's
also in denial about immigration yeah
let me explain how some of these affect
regular Americans and it's not to say
that you guys don't know this but
regular Americans are who we're talking
to at home immigration that for example
my dad was a brick and block Mason he
charged we'll just put a random number
out there a125 cents a block that's what
it took for him to hire three or four
laborers another Mason pay for the
materials to get there lay the block and
make just enough money on the back end
that if it took an extra day or two of
Labor he still made money if Hispanics
come in and back in the '90s and 2000s
it was Hispanics but was Southern border
now who knows but if illegal migrants
come in and they don't have to pay for
Social Security disability they don't
have to pay for insurance they don't
have to pay taxes and they can lay that
block for 50 cents of block you know
what happens my dad is forcibly retired
at 56 years old and dies at 63 from
probably alcoholism and a broken heart
so this issue attacked my family right
headon it attacked my dad's career it
took it away from him left him to his
worst vulnerabilities and that's not
anybody's fault but his but I saw this
issue really attack my hometown and my
family and I say that having grown up
with the kids of illegal immigrants that
I love and call friends and fellow
Americans right so it is a it is an
issue that's hard to wrap your hand
around and have one opinion or the other
but it's an issue that attacks the lower
class and lower middle class you look at
inflation how do poor people have a
chance at at getting ahead in life they
borrow Capital to invest in their ideas
and their hard work you can't do that if
that money costs more than you can pay
back
and that's where we are what's your
number one means of gaining Capital if
you're poor and you don't have something
is your home if you happen to have paid
some of it off so we're going to borrow
money at at 6 and a half 7% you can't do
that for to take a risk on a on a
starting a business so there's so much
about this that yeah you can show you
know groceries don't cost quite as much
or Energy's coming down a little bit or
mortgage rates are coming down a little
bit but the situation in its in its
entirety looks really Bleak for people
just trying to get a step up well people
can't the American dream will not exist
if people cannot go out and afford homes
and home prices right now are
unaffordable for the majority of
Americans not to mention the interest
rates savings you have to have the
ability to acove savings but when you
look at these numbers Americans are
living paycheck to paycheck even though
it's making $100,000 and more this is
not a sustainable situation right now in
this economy first time Bo home buy
buyers are out they're just completely
out they can't afford it and home prices
right now have not returned to
pre-pandemic levels and the interest
rates are crazy now the interest rates
are supposed to be going down sometime
in the spring early summer going down
from super crazy to just really crazy
aage above average considering what we
had under the Trump Administration all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else